make no mistake Justice in this country
is no longer blind this is very sad for
this country the FBI has in fact been
politicized and the FBI and the doj have
both been weaponized it is sad but this
is very very real and needs to be dealt
with in fact they actively now and
knowingly are putting their thumb on the
scale they've done it now in every major
election since 2016 including 2016. but
that's news apparently to FBI director
Christopher Ray who's on Capitol Hill
today take a look at this
you know I hear these claims of
politicization but I can tell you that
the FBI is and it's going to stay
independent and that means following the
facts wherever they lead no matter who
likes it and I can tell you that is not
true unless of course the facts could
negatively impact a prominent Democrat
with the last name Clinton or Biden Ray
is either lying or living on another
planet now remember according to Jim
Comey no reasonable prosecutor would
ever bring charges against Hillary
Clinton she had all that top secret
classified information on her servers
after she was caught mishandling a ton
of top secret material and then of
course she destroyed evidence the 33 000
emails we had never heard of bleach pit
before everybody now knows what bleach
bit is and of course then there were
blackberries and iPhones that were
smashed with hammers and of course they
also removed SIM cards so you could
never recover any information on those
blackberries and iPhones now the FBI
never bothered to raid Hillary Clinton's
chop Chappaqua Mansion I wonder why
Hannity they didn't want to see me
that's why I I why didn't they raid that
more recently the FBI never bothered to
conduct a search warrant at any of Joe
Biden's properties after top secret
documents turned up here there and
pretty much everywhere Joe Biden was now
apparently early morning raids with SWAT
teams they are specifically reserved for
Donald Trump or his friends and
Associates like Paul manafort or Roger
Stone or other conservatives other
Republicans because we are now living in
a country with a two-tiered system of
justice now director Ray had a chance to
restore the Integrity of the FBI to once
again make it the single Premier law
enforcement agency in the entire world
after the disastrous tenure of James
Comey and Company but instead the Euros
political bias and abuse of power it is
now worse than ever Christopher Ray is
an abject failure no America American
should have confidence in his leadership
you decide
the documents investigation for former
president Trump and the raid that
happens in Mar-A-Lago that show of force
in that way as opposed to the documents
investigation for President Biden and
how that went down you find out about
those documents before the November
election the FBI then does the search of
the house after that but does not say
anything prior to the midterm election
so we have a long history of handling
investigations into the mishandling of
classified information and our standard
for approaching those investigations is
the same no matter who it is our basic
approach is the same
that too is not true that do you believe
that true the truth equal treatment
regardless of politics he's saying
really uh how do you explain then the
Curious Case of Hunter Biden remember
the FBI got possession of the laptop
from hell in December of 2019. now
instead of authenticating the laptop and
investigating the variety of potential
crimes documented on the laptop well
what did Christopher Rey's FBI do well
prior to the 2020 election the bureau
they were warnings every big Tech social
media company in the country they were
doing it on a weekly basis to be on high
alert for foreign disinformation and it
may be about Joe Biden and it may even
be about Hunter Biden so when the very
true New York Post report came out about
hunter's laptop and that was released
Big Tech they had already been primed
week after week after week after week by
FBI agents people that work for
Christopher Ray eagerly assuming what
they were told was coming that was some
type of disinformation campaign from a
foreign entity well it worked
successfully because all the big tech
companies they censored the story weeks
before the 2020 presidential election
which I would argue and polls have shown
likely contributed to tipping the
election to Joe Biden mission
accomplished right Chris Ray now how
dirty can this get you decide
the FBI does not it is not in the
business of functioning as the truth
police we don't tell social media
companies to censor anything no he you
just told them on a weekly basis to be
on the lookout they may have
misinformation about Joe and Hunter
Biden what do you think they were going
to do as a result of that your FBI
agents did it on a weekly basis they
don't tell social media media companies
to censor they just feed them false
information to create a false narrative
all in the hope to shape the results of
an election and the company's policies
and by the way the FBI was doing this
every single solitary week leading up to
the 2020 presidential election not only
did the FBI plant the seeded
disinformation in big Tech but they also
sat idly by and said nothing remember
when 50 former Intel officials with no
proof at all whatsoever they signed off
on a letter claiming that Hunter Biden's
laptop has all the classic earmarks of
Russian disinformation or a Russian
information operation they had the FBI
had the laptop 11 months prior to the
presidential election in 2020 this is
disgusting it is corrupt it is a
National Disgrace they knew it wasn't
Russian disinformation but they had an
election to win they had a favored
candidate his name was well he can't
remember it but we remember Joe Biden
and by the way
Chris Ray doesn't want to answer any
questions about that matter either he
ducked he dodged he obfuscated left and
right in this interview with Brett Baer
take a look
I can't speak to what former officials
of the intelligence community may or may
not have said I can only speak to what
we do and unfortunately as you would
expect if we're going to do this
investigation in the right way that
means I can't talk about the specifics
of that investigation other than to
assure everyone that I expect our people
to tackle this investigation the way
that I expect them to tackle every
investigation which is to follow the
facts wherever they lead no matter who
likes it okay there's always somebody
who doesn't like it you've had the
laptop for three plus years you had the
laptop 11 months before the presidential
election you could have verified that
probably in a matter of 72 hours max now
during a very revealing interview with
Brett Bear as I said he ducked he dodged
every single solitary question he
obfuscated the FBI director seems to
think that he is accountable to nobody
and by the way this is you know this
isn't just about Trump and Biden and the
presidential election it's about
political bias in our justice system at
the FBI the doj that becomes the threat
to anybody that maybe they don't like
whatever group it happens to be for
example angry parents at school board
meetings remember they were recently
labeled and being investigated as
potential domestic terrorists oh they
don't want CRT or they don't want uh
transgender education for kids in in
kindergarten traditional Catholics
remember they were targeted at their
place of worship dozens of Americans had
their bank records turned over to the
FBI all because they took a bus to
Washington D.C to hear a rally on
January 6 2021 they didn't break any
laws but if you try to light a federal
courthouse on fire in Portland OR
participated in 574 violent riots in the
summer of 2020 you likely never faced
any real investigation that is a
two-tier justice system that's what
we're talking about that is apparently
also true if you're firebombed an
emergency Pregnancy Center or vandalize
the church out of 250 recent attacks
Christopher Reyes FBI only brought
charges against two of these violent
criminals that's it but they did manage
to send a SWAT team guns drawn to the
home of a pro-life activist who shoved a
man allegedly harassing his son near an
abortion clinic but don't expect an
explanation from Chris Ray take a look
here's what I'm talking about is the
Dual system you know there's that for a
pro-life activist but not that for a
black lives matter protester who maybe
torches a federal building over the
summer so that disparity that dichotomy
is what sticks in people's mind I
understand that people have their
opinions all I can tell you is that we
have one standard
one standard which is irrespective of
ideology of politics
that is a Croc of Adam Schiff I don't
believe any of that
their one standard thank you they're
their one standard conservatives
Republicans they get targeted while
violent criminals on the left they get a
free pass I think it's obvious it is
clear it is transparent so director Ray
needs to resign or he needs to be fired
and frankly the FBI and the doj may need
to be dismantled to bring back the honor
and integrity that it once had but that
likely won't happen under Joe Biden
because
Christopher Ray is dutifully serving the
Biden Administration they're part of the
executive branch of government and today
Biden's attorney general Merrick Garland
well he echoed his colleagues at the FBI
what a shocker take a look
a Catholic pro-life demonstrator father
who's accused of disorderly conduct in
front of an abortion Center
the local prosecutor the Philadelphia
district attorney who is a Democrat a
liberal very Progressive declined to
prosecute there was a private suit that
got dismissed
and then after all of that your justice
department sent between 20 and 30 armed
agents in the early morning hours to the
house private residence to arrest this
guy after he had offered to turn himself
in voluntarily determinations of how to
make arrests under arrest warrants are
made based by the Tactical operators in
the district but you certainly looked
into it by this point right
you know the answer surely they all I
know is what the FBI has said which is
that they made decisions on the ground
as to what was safest and easiest
so get this the doj is perfectly fine
with sending a SWAT team in that
scenario but they won't even bring
charges against anybody that was doxing
or harassing or threatening U.S Supreme
Court Justices at their homes watch this
have you brought a single case against
any of these protesters threatening the
Judgment justices under 18 USC section
1507. you brought even one Senator you
asked me whether I sat on my hands and
quite of the opposite I sent 70 United
States Marshals try again
has the Department of Justice brought
even a single case under the statute say
yes no question it's not a give a speech
on the other things you did the job of
the United States Marshals is to defend
the lives so the answer is no is to
defend the lives of the justices and
that's their number one priority they
have why are you unwilling to say no the
answer is no you know it's no I know
it's no everyone in this in this hearing
room knows it's no you're not willing to
answer a question
as far as I know we haven't
Checkmate Ted Cruz that was slam dunk
all right let's be clear
a politicized that weaponized justice
system will not stand the test of time
but in the meantime Ray and Garland
don't seem to care hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else